ROMAN NURIK: Hello, and welcome
to Android Design in Action.
My name's Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: Hi,
I'm Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And to
your right is Mike.
MIKE DENNY: Hi.
Yeah, my name's Mike Denny.
This is my first Android
Design in Action.
I'm excited to be a part of it.
I just joined Google a couple
weeks ago as a design advocate
for developer relations.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, so
pretty soon hopefully
you guys are going to see
a bunch of material, Design
Bytes and things like
that, coming from Mike.
He's a very talented
speaker and awesome guy.
Yeah, so look forward to
hearing from Mike very soon.
NICK BUTCHER: Welcome Mike.
Great to see you on the
show more in the future.
MIKE DENNY: Great to be here.
ROMAN NURIK: So
in today's episode
of Android Design
in Action, we're
going to be looking at a
couple of our favorite apps.
And actually, not just us, but
members from the larger Android
team, specifically some of
the designers on the team,
are going to be looking at
some of their favorite design
aspects of their favorite apps.
NICK BUTCHER: So
hopefully we're going
to give you some little
sprinkles of inspiration
of things that we
love to see in apps
and hopefully give you some
ideas of the kind of elements
that you can
include in your apps
to make them equally compelling.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
So without further
ado, let's get to it.
So the app I want to
talk about is Foursquare.
Now, I'm sure a lot
of you folks out
there are familiar
with Foursquare.
You probably use it every day.
But I just wanted to point out
a couple of specific design
features that I really
love about this app.
Now, specifically, I'm going
to do a search for something
like pizza and
see what comes up.
And I'll talk
through the process.
So first, I'm going to go ahead
and enter this search field.
I'm going to start typing pizza.
And actually, before
I type anything,
you'll notice that
I have a couple
of different suggestions, a
couple different categories
of food or I guess
of places that I
can look in, which is great.
But I'm going to go
ahead and type pizza.
And you'll notice
that immediately, it
gives me a bunch
of common searches.
So you have pizza, Pizza
Hut, pizza place, and so on.
I'm just going to go
ahead and choose pizza.
Now, once I get into
here, this is really
the meat of what I want to
talk about, no pun intended.
So on the left here-- and this
is a tablet UI-- on the left,
you have the list
of search results.
On the right, you have this map.
So this is kind of a
very common two-pane view
for lists of search results.
Now, the most interesting
thing here, I guess,
is what happens with the
actual list of search results.
If you look on the
left here, you'll
notice that it's not just
the title and the category
or the title and the photo.
There's actually a
lot of information
compressed into
this small space.
So for example, Amici's
East Coast Pizzeria here,
you see that it's a $1 sign.
It's got a couple of friends
of mine that have been there.
It shows this to me immediately
in the form of avatars.
It actually shows the
photos of my friends
that have been here, which is
a really nice signal that hey,
this is important.
This may be a
really good result.
And it actually
kind of brings up
the score, the rating of
the restaurant, as well.
So if I scroll through
here, you notice
that the information
hierarchy is very clear.
The very first thing you see,
the very most obvious thing
in the search
results, is the photo.
But after your eye
glances at the photo,
you immediately take a
look and start processing
the other information
on the screen, things
like the title, the type,
the category, and then
who's been there.
Now, so that's kind of one of
my favorite pieces of this app
is it really has so much.
It really communicates so much
in a very interesting way.
Really quickly, I
wanted to point out
that the typography
here is very good.
The information
hierarchy is further
complimented by the use of
things like Roboto Light.
So for example, pizza, pizza,
pizza, Italian, Italian, and so
on.
These categories are
kind of repetitive.
It's not adding too
much to my sense
of what this place is about.
And so it's actually using
a slightly lighter font
to distract me less while I'm
looking at the different search
results.
So the other nice thing I
wanted to point out real quick
is let's say, you
know, I've seen
this first page of results.
And I start scrolling down.
Now, usually when
you start scrolling
in a set of search results,
it means that you haven't yet
found what you wanted to find.
So as I start
scrolling, you'll notice
that this bar at
the bottom pops up
that says, hey, if you haven't
found what you want yet,
maybe you're looking
for something else.
Try searching for food, dinner,
Italian, or lunch, or things
like that.
And so these kind
of contextual cues
are really important to overall
making the search results
and search experience
really key.
There are obviously other
nice things involved here,
like as I touch
items in the map,
they focus in on the
left in this list.
But these are really some
of my favorite features,
this information hierarchy,
this bottom bar that
shows up at the bottom.
Overall, this is just a great
search results experience
in the Foursquare app.
RACHEL GARB: Hi, I'm Rachel.
I'm going to tell
you about things
I really like about
the Airbnb app.
First of all, what's great is
that you can jump right in.
You don't have to
sign in or sign up.
You can immediately start
looking at the content
and enjoying it.
And the content
is just beautiful.
We have full bleed images
and beautiful typography.
The key information
is there at a glance,
which is the price, of course.
And once you drill into
the details, same thing.
It's beautifully laid out.
The transition is satisfying
to look at for a few seconds.
And you can swipe
through and really
quickly get all the
information that you
need about a particular place.
Call to action very obvious.
And also lots of
sharing options.
So if you're trying to
make a decision about where
to stay with other people,
very easy to get to that.
For something that's
supposed to be work,
this makes it a lot
more fun and enjoyable.
MARCO PAGLIA: Hi everybody.
My name is Marco.
I'm an Android
designer, and I lead
a set of different
applications that we work on
on Android Design, in
particular, Google Play.
So today I'm going to be talking
to you about a new application
that we have just
finished working on
and has just been released,
which is Newsstand,
and we're very proud about.
We're just going to be
looking into some details
that I really like.
So here's the
Newsstand application.
It's a typical play application.
It has a side drawer
with all the sections.
And we've built these
very beautiful cards
as you sign in in order to tell
you what the experiences are
about, what my news is about,
what [INAUDIBLE] is about,
et cetera.
And you can just dismiss them.
We have a nice animation.
Everything feels very fluid.
Let me get to another
detail that I really like.
These are all my sources.
It's a mix between
sources that I
follow, like "The
Verge," and topics.
Every topic has a
different color.
Google Play is blue.
Google is red.
Architecture at the
bottom is purple.
So let me open that
one in particular.
You see the action
bar changes color
according to the
topic where I'm in.
And we spent a lot of
time doing it right.
And actually, all the
rendering is done dynamically.
And then look when I
slide, when I edge swipe
and I open the drawer.
The action bar color itself
back into the application color.
And this is very nice.
This is a detail we spent
a lot of time doing it.
Let me do that again.
You see the color just merges
into the application's color.
I'm going to look
into another detail.
Let's check the sources instead.
Let's check "The Verge."
There you go.
This is "The Verge."
You see that we wanted to give
to a particular source a very
emotional feeling.
So you have an image,
which is in the background.
And with a sort of
Ken Burns effect,
it's fading out
different images.
It feels very much alive.
And as soon as I
scroll up the view,
the logo moves right
into its position,
and the source name shows up.
And that's another detail
that we spent a lot of time
doing it right, and
we think it really
distinguishes this
application from others.
Let's look at another detail.
Let's look at the article view.
We have developed a lot
of different layouts
so that the articles feel
very unique and beautiful
on all devices.
I'm going to look at "The
New York Times," which
is a source that we
worked with in details.
So you see in the
"New York Times,"
you have all your news
as for everything else.
But the font in the "New
York Times" is personalized.
It's the "New York Times" font.
It's not Roboto as
we use it elsewhere.
So we try to make every
source to be different
from one another,
to be very specific.
So when you look at
the "Financial Times,"
it has a different font,
and so on and so forth.
So we invite,
actually, the developer
to try to play with
different fonts
if they have them available.
So see this detail here.
This news right now is metered.
So I only have 18 free
articles that I can read today.
And if I want to read it, I
can just swipe up the page.
And you see the number
is changing into 10.
And when it reaches
the end, there you go.
Now the page is unlocked,
and now I can scroll it,
and I can finally read it.
This is something else we spent
quite a bit of time doing it.
And every layout is
really beautiful.
Let me show you a couple
of my favorite articles
that I have saved here.
This is an article
about a new car,
the Stingray that just came out.
See when you're in article
view, the action bar
disappears as soon as
you get into the article.
And it's full of beautiful
photos, beautiful photos
everywhere that we
got from the source.
Now check this out.
We want to have the
view to be full screen
and to be very immersive, so
I don't see the action bar
when I'm navigating
through the page.
But as soon as I pull this
down, the action bar comes back.
But I haven't finished.
Look when I get all the way up.
The action bar
becomes transparent
as it reaches the
end, and it wants
to melt with the
rest of the view
and not feel like a colored
thing on top of the view.
So these are just
some of the examples
that we worked on in order
to make this application feel
special, feel
immersive, and feel
very different from a lot of
other applications we built
so far.
It has very individual patterns
that we invite everybody
to play with so that we can
have more patterns, more
differentiation, and better
application across the Android
platform.
Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Hi.
The app that I have
selected to talk about
is Chrome, the browser.
And in particular, I'd like to
talk about some of the gestures
that they use in
the application.
So here I am in
Chrome app, looking
at a particularly interesting
playlist on YouTube.
And you can see from
the little three
up here and just
next to the URL bar
that I have three tabs open.
So I can just go ahead
and tap that button,
and I'll get into the
tab management UI.
But another more interesting
way of doing this
is using a gesture.
You can see that when I tap that
three, the bar itself animates
down, kind of shifts down,
kind of implying spatially
how you might bootstrap this,
the knowledge of this gesture.
So what you can do is
you can drag it down
and to enter the same
UI here from the bar.
So a few things about how
they've done this gesture I
think work really, really well.
Firstly, I always
feel in control of it.
So as I drag down, it
kind of tracks my finger
so I can move down
and up, and I always
feel very much in control
of what's going on.
The second thing is
it's very contextual.
So if I was on, say, this
bottom tab here, as I drag down,
it maintains the
order of my tabs.
But it tracks my fingers.
So again, I always feel
very much in control,
and it retains the context
of where I've come from.
You can also do some things
like dragging sideways
on it to switch the tabs here.
So again, it's maintaining
that spatial model
so I know I can move
on easily to them.
And my favorite thing
I think about this
is just the element of whimsy.
As per the Android
design guidelines,
you should be aiming to delight
your users in surprising ways.
This task you're doing,
the goal I guess,
is managing tabs, is switching
between tabs, closing a tab.
Could be seen as
kind of a chore,
something you're
forcing the user to do.
But by introducing a really
satisfying way of doing it,
it actually makes
it more delightful.
So action here, say dragging
down and then swiping away,
is kind of much more visceral.
Using direct manipulation
to actually grab the content
and manipulate it, rather
than operating machinery
to perform a task I think
is really, really great.
So yeah, that was
gestures in Google Chrome.
Great job, and
think about how you
might use similar
kind of gestures
to make tasks more directly
manipulated and more fun.
Cheers.
RICHARD FELCHER: Hi, this is
Rich Felcher on the Android
Design team, and I'm here
today to talk about an app
that I've been using for a
couple of years now called
Libra.
Libra is an app
that is used to help
you keep track of your weight.
It does a lot of
things that I like.
It does things like
prompting you every day
with a notification to
enter your weight, so
positive little
reminders like that.
But the thing I wanted
to focus on today
is the way that Libra visualizes
the data that the user enters
over time and how it
can kind of respond
to different scales of time
when showing that data.
So in the typical
view for Libra,
you're seeing a graph of
your most recent weights
that you've entered
within the application.
So here I've got a couple of
weeks' worth of content here.
And for every day, I'm just
seeing a small orange dot
that represents what the
value on a particular day was.
And they've got the
gray lines connecting it
to the average, which is a
trend line that's rolling back
across several days of data.
It also does some forecasting,
so you get this kind of line
to the right hand
side here that's
kind of predicting if you
continue the way you've
been doing and
managing your meals,
your weight should
go in that direction.
What Libra does that's really
kind of well implemented
and smoothly done
is, if I decide
to shift this time scale--
so maybe I want to go back,
and I look across a slightly
wider scope of time--
as I do that, the
way that the data is
being reflected
actually changes.
So now those orange
circles have dropped away.
I still have the gray
bars, so I can still
get a sense of what those
individual day values were.
But that's honestly just
less important in this view.
And if I keep squeezing
out a little further,
the gray lines
themselves disappear,
and I'm really just
looking at trend over time.
It also, in addition to kind of
doing the two-finger gestures,
I can do tap to snap to
different time scales.
So tap once, and then tap
again to get closer and closer.
And you'll see it moves
through those different views,
and there's even
little shortcuts
for moving to the current
day view and matching that.
So a neat small app,
something I maybe spend
less than 30 seconds
with each day.
But still does a really
good job of considering
kind of what the user
goals are at any instant.
If I am in the moment of
putting in that one value,
it's giving me a real detailed
view for a short range.
But as I start to go
further and further out
to look for a wider
set of data, it really
adapts and kind of
simplifies the views
so that only the most
pertinent things to the user
are displayed, and I can kind
of quickly glance and read
and understand what's happening.
So that's Libra.
Recommended.
Thanks.
MIKE DENNY: So the app I'm
going to be talking about today
is Timely by the
awesome guys at Bitspin.
So Timely, if you've been
following Android design,
if you've seen the show,
we've talked about it before.
It's been discussed a lot
on different platforms
because it's just a fantastic
example of Android design,
and it just really encapsulates
a lot of the design principles
in the Android design
guide, especially principles
around the idea that our Android
devices should enchant us.
And I'm specifically going to
be talking about things that
stand out in this
app that just show
that they went the extra mile.
They have just an awesome
level of polish in this app.
And this kind of
polish isn't just
the fundamental things
in your app are working.
Timely, for example, is a
clock, a timer, a stopwatch,
and I use it as an alarm to
wake me up in the morning.
So all that stuff
behaves as expected,
but it's the extra
little details.
It's the tiny animations
that are just gorgeous,
and the use of color, the use of
typography throughout the app.
It's that extra 1% effort that
really makes a huge difference
in the overall quality
of your app experience.
So like I mentioned,
it's a clock,
and if you look at the seconds
animating here, and even
responding to my touch,
it's just a perfect example
in dozens of places in this
app that real objects are
more fun than buttons and menus.
So just up here,
at first glance,
this doesn't look like a
traditional Android app, right?
It doesn't have a
solid color action
bar with a light or
dark theme throughout.
It's bright, it's colored, it's
got this live wallpaper thing
going on in the background.
But it behaves like
an Android app,
and that makes the
beautiful aesthetic
that they've gone with
just that much better.
When you page between
the different colors,
they kind of crossfade.
And all of these
elements are touchable.
They're very inviting.
You don't have to be told
explicitly what to do.
For example, you just
hit the play button,
and it starts counting down
from the time I set for it.
And if you're
interacting with it
and you get a little
bit off track,
and you start dragging here,
you notice that it tilts.
And so that's kind
of curious, right?
And so if you go down to the
split action bar on the bottom
and tap the
stopwatch button, you
notice that the timer
actually flips end over end.
And so that kind
of gives me the cue
that I can just flip
it using a gesture,
and I don't even have to worry
about the button down here.
And that's just a lot more fun.
When there are things that
are a little bit harder
to communicate to a new
user, for example, like how
to drag from the edge here
to create a new alarm,
it's gently taught.
So I can swipe from
the edge of the screen
and pull in a new alarm
and set it for 6:30,
and I have that nice
pulse to interact with.
It shows me here that I
can tap below to increment
or tap above to reduce the time.
And when I'm done, I
just hit done at the top.
And there I've set an alarm,
and it's just awesome.
So I can move it up and down.
Very interactive
throughout the app.
So just again, I
want to emphasize
that this is that extra 1%
of effort that just makes
it possible to delight your
users, surprise your users.
Because it's not generic.
The things in your app
that just make them smile,
make you think, oh,
somebody thought of that.
That extra percent
of effort is going
to make a lot of difference
and have that polish that
will really make a great
experience for your users.
ADAM KOCH: So for those of
you unfamiliar with Etsy,
it's essentially an online
marketplace for handmade goods.
So you can browse the various
goods that are available
and then of course purchase
and have them delivered to you.
So let me go ahead and
open up this application.
I've just downloaded and
installed it from Google Play,
so I haven't run it before.
And you'll notice immediately
I'm shown content.
So I'm not thrown up into
any sort of roadblocks,
no tutorial, no login required.
I just immediately see these
sort of trending items on Etsy.
So I think that's
really great, and I'm
pretty sure Nick
Butcher would be pretty
happy with this onboarding flow.
Now, if I scroll down, you'll
notice this staggered grid view
layout of the various items.
And I really like this as well.
It really means that instead
of a traditional square kind
of grid, it means
that the images don't
need to be cropped quite
so much to get them down
into that square.
So you can see more images.
Like this one on the left
here, this black sweater--
this back sweater, rather.
You can see more
of the image there.
It fits nicer onto the screen.
The other great thing
about this layout
is it will work very well
across different screen sizes.
So I think on
phone, in portrait,
they just show one column.
But then as the screen
size gets bigger,
they move to multiple columns.
So I think it's really nice.
Another thing worth mentioning
is you'll see here--
and it's kind of hard
to notice as I scroll
through-- but the
placeholder images
that they show before
the image actually
fades in-- now these images
are just loading so fast,
it's really hard to see.
OK, here we go.
You'll notice there's sort of
a composite of the image that's
eventually going to load there.
So for example, this ornament,
which is sort of primarily
green and brown, it was sort
of a green/brown combination
shade of color.
So I'll scroll down a little bit
more so you can see a few more.
So I really like that.
There you go.
You can see a bit better.
Now, their touch
feedback is very subtle.
You can see here.
It actually fits in very
nicely with the updated
recommendations after Android
4.4 KitKat was announced.
So that's quite nice as well.
One of my favorite
things actually
of this app I'm
about to show you
now is as you open
the drawer, you'll
notice they kind of blur
out the actual content here.
I think this is a really
nice design flourish,
and it really helps
to put the focus
on the drawer, which
just popped open.
So if I close it
again, the images
just fade back into being
nice and clear again.
It's great because they actually
blur whatever the content was
that was on the
screen at the time.
So here, let me do it again.
Quite nice.
Now, if you try and
like something--
so I'm going to tap
this little heart here
in one of the corners--
now, at this point,
you do need to
sign up or sign in.
They've got a clear
button that says, not now.
So if you don't want
to go down that path,
you can just click that
and continue on your way.
But if you do want
to sign in, you
can just continue on with this
flow, sign in appropriately.
And they also use that
blurred-out effect here again,
and I think it just
looks really nice.
Popping quickly into
the details screen.
So this is an item that
I'm sure many of you
will be interested in,
a tortoise cozy, yes.
So again, this layout, it's
very focused on the content.
There's not a lot of
system UI going on here,
really it's just the
action bar, a description,
and the key actions there
either in the action bar
or within the actual layout.
And then as you sort of
scroll down the description,
you'll see these additional
images pop up from the bottom.
These are sort of other items
from this particular seller.
So if you're really into
getting turtle cozies,
you can see here you've
got plenty to look through.
So that's it.
I just thought this
was a fantastic app.
Check it out.
Thanks very much.
ROMAN NURIK: So those are some
of our favorite design details
and some of our favorite apps.
We hope that you guys drew
some inspiration from some
of the things we
talked about today.
And that's all we have
for this week's episode.
As always, I'm your
host, Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And
I'm Nick Butcher.
MIKE DENNY: And I'm Mike Denny.
ROMAN NURIK: Until next
time, thanks, guys.
NICK BUTCHER: Thanks.